hello there the war is over io have been
defeated for now and the island is in
bloom the zero point is free and this
season changes are everywhere so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes think
about using adamaru and let's break down
everything from story related
shenanigans to sheer madness
let's check up on the zero point first
and as you can see it's happily sitting
underwater recovering from everything
it's been through it looks to be
perfectly intact and in the best
condition we've seen it since the first
day on the map back at the unvolting
also under the water are a few
references to the battle to free the
nexus io remnants can be spotted by
their drills we blew up in the live
event here at the collider it's been
repurposed for the summer and look
batman's favorite floaty is here too
from last summer a disco floor is inside
this building and a casino next door
this season really is all about relaxing
the war is over peace is here even the
formidable fortress is now just a
decoration for the islanders it's like a
giant morris dancing pole
[Music]
speaking of the war in the live event
during the battle the mech took heavy
damage leaving the rex arm on the ground
and it sits there right now it's lost an
eye and looks impossible to repair it
may stay here for seasons like the other
mech arm i tried to find that one from
the first mech but i couldn't because a
new biome now sits here and the island
is bigger check out reality falls an
update which we really do need to keep
tabs on is found here the zero points
bloom has given us a reality tree
bustling with unknown energy in norse
mythology a tree like this holds
together all realities and acts like a
hub between all of them i'm banking on
this place being important soon and
here's why roots check them out this
tree has laid tons of roots everywhere
and by the looks of it it's only just
beginning to spread let's think forward
could the tree become corrupted could it
take over the island or is it just
spreading the positivity i'll be sure to
keep an eye on it and let you know oh
bad news now i must interrupt this video
to pass on some very unpleasant news
during the war with the io we lost a
hero clumbo his remains can now be found
in the snow just below crackshot's cabin
to pay your respects please press the
like button and use code adamaru r.i.p
clonbo
the biggest update on the island is at
command cavern as io have been removed
this place is now the life of the party
the rave cave colour is everywhere a few
really cool things to know here first
check out the new tv walls so impressive
but also in here you can find the new
and improved pizza pit okay it's not
improved it's less than impressive but
it's back in business with a functioning
kitchen and a spacious sitting room the
roller coaster we always wanted back in
chapter one is finally here and look
there's a tribute to pili currently
being built for his heroics during the
live event the new coaster is also
joined by the return of slipstreams many
fans loved back in chapter one season
nine and that's where another important
point must be made every single version
of the island we've seen is somewhere
around this place for example by the
main dance floor in the cave is this
plane wreckage recognize it this is the
og fuselage from day one of chapter two
the day a new world was created the ego
logo can still be seen on top of this
this thing is history and wait there's
more look in the south west and you'll
find the displaced depot it's one of the
containers from chapter one before the
meteor crashed we kinda saw it in
chapter two as well there's also the
huge chair again from chapter one this
changed shapes many times over the years
and now it's back four years later and
then nearby is a chapter two landmark
the shark one of the most amazing
updates from the midas season a
villain's lair like no other we're just
scratching the surface but there's so
many previous seasons referenced anyway
going back up to the reality tree here's
something you really should know venture
here and you'll find some rock which
seems unbreakable it has millions of
health points it turns out someone or
something is in there mining slowly
trying to get out
of course legendary leaker fort tory has
already figured it out inside this mound
of rocks is the bromance the henchman
from chapter two they are coming back
this season but they have a lot of work
in front of them before we see them
again it's actually possible to get in
there right now but i don't want to be
the one who ruins this community event
for everyone maybe maybe in a myth
chaser episode
up at the very north of the map is a poi
under construction wash out wharf wood
has arrived and been stockpiled at this
building here it's a shell right now
there's nothing much to report but would
you like to predict what will be built
here maybe some sort of superstar again
or i'm thinking a shipyard the toilets
are being delivered as we speak which is
the most important room in the house i'm
told remember the solitary wobbly blob
which sits on the cove to the left of
logjam he's still there nothing's
changed here but little does he know
that there's more of his kind down in
the new biome the start of their
comeback finally begins now and in the
meantime we can just vibe to the music
oh before we crack on look under the
water around here and you'll find this
what the heck is it is it a new hatch is
it just a piece of debris which has
fallen like this what is this i must
know please help over to greasy grove
now and it's been absolutely decimated
by the fungal uprising the taco store is
a little higher than it used to be well
half of it is anyway and the basement
underneath is in ruin this entire place
does not look good health and safety
will be on their way soon once again
we'll keep an eye on it i'll let you
know next week over to tilted towers now
and the renovations have begun the wall
left this poi in tatters right now those
ruins are slowly being cleaned up the
debris is being removed and salvageable
buildings like the clock tower are being
rebuilt and good old no sweat insurance
is still standing strong supposedly
tilted will be the new home of the block
an ever-changing community-created poi
that existed back in chapter 1. i
thought if this came back it would be at
the old volcano due to the pop in from
distance but no i'm wrong the daily
bugles still stand strong for a third
season over the island the theme of
rebuilding and repurposing continues the
old yellow house that was destroyed near
tilted towers is currently on its way
back to greatness all the former io
scout towers have now been covered in
paint and effectively are party zones
and there's even new jetties which can
be found in the water all around the
island everything this season just
screams party time
i think we've waited long enough to talk
about the stone family check them out
this week they are now fully chilled by
the beach dad is chugging down barrels
of slurp the kid is building a sand
castle better than anyone i've ever seen
made in my entire life and check out
mama sunbathing with a book but not just
any book that my friends is cypher pk's
playbook from chapter 2. mama is gonna
learn how to crank 90s this season so i
feel it's a time to challenge you can
you take this book with you from the
start of the game all the way to the
final circle and get a win oh it's not
indestructible anymore oh well cancel
that request and the dog by the way
looks to have spotted something in the
boat maybe this is the start of a new
adventure next week around the map tons
of rebuilding spots have popped up like
this one just below sanctuary the bomb
craters have now been filled and a new
road marking is laid out yet the
greatest update of all is a little
further north by kony the crash site of
cars and buses is changing pili used
this spot to um
practice driving last season and luckily
that turned out well as he became the
savior of reality right now though the
bus is stood up on its end held up by a
telephone pole you already know what
this will become more confirmation that
truckasaurus is coming it may take some
time to reassemble this guy and get a
new coat of paint but soon he will be
here okay so that is all the map updates
that i spotted did i miss anything be
sure to leave a comment or at me on
twitter and i'll add it next week i hope
you enjoy this summer update i'll see
you next time this week's legends are
taken from my discord thank you very
much for using my code
[Music]